TENNESSEE ALL RIGHT, JOINING TO
GREAT ONE AND HE DESERVES IT,
ABOUT TO HOST A BRAND NEW SHOW
RIGHT HERE THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
IT'S LIKE PULLING TEETH TO GET
HIM ON MY SHOW.
LIFE, LIBERTY AND LEVIN.
HOST OF LEVIN TV.
THE GREAT ONE.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO WASTE OUR
TIME.
THIS FISA, YOU TALK ABOUT A
POST-CONSTITUTIONAL AMERICA,
MARK.
YOUR BOOKS ON THE CONSTITUTION
ARE PHENOMENAL, MUST-READ BY
ANYBODY WHO CARES ABOUT IT.
WE'RE SEEING A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE FIX A PRIMARY, WHO
GETS AN EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATION WITH COMEY AND
STRUCK, TRIES TO FIX -- TALKING
ABOUT HILLARY.
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA.
THEN THOSE LAWS ARE USED TO GET
A FISA WARRANT AGAINST THE
OPPOSITION CANDIDATE AND
INCOMING.
AND HIS TEAM F THAT'S NOT POST
>> COUPLE OF THINGS ABOUT THAT.
AS AN OLD CHIEF OF STAFF TO AN
FIRST OF ALL, LET ME SAY THIS,
AS AN AMERICAN CITIZEN TO WATCH
THIS IS REPULSIVE,
UNCONSCIONABLE, TO WATCH THE MOB
MEDIA DO WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
LAST WEEK WE WERE TOLD THE
TOLD ME'S CLUING WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
TODAY WE ARE -- COLLUDING WITH
MENTALLY UNSTABLE, A RACIST.
>> GOING TO START A NUCLEAR WAR.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT YOU
ATOR, MICHAEL WOLFF, THREE
DAYSING ON HE WAS THE IN THING,
NOW HE'S GONE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE ALLEGATIONS
ABOUT SEXUAL MISCONDUCT, THAT'S
ALL GONE.
A CONFIDENTIAL MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND OTHER SENATORS,
HE'S RELIED ON BY THE MEDIA
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO RELY ON
HIM, JUST LIKE THEY WANTED TO
RELY ON THAT AUTHOR.
THEY WANT TO PUSH THIS PRESIDENT
OUT.
TALK ABOUT THE 25th AMENDMENT.
GUARD MEDIA.
-- THE PRETORIAN GUARD MEDIA.
THE PLI TIZATION AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE FBI AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
NOT A QUESTION OF JIM COMEY,
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR LEAKED.
THE QUESTION IS HOW MUCH DID HE
LEAK.
NOT A QUESTION IF HE LEAKED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, THE
QUESTION IS HOW MUCH CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION?
HE WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
THE CHIEF INVESTIGATOR WHO WAS
HUNTING DOWN DONALD TRUMP.
SENDING TEXTS TO HIS GIRLFRIEND,
BECAUSE HE'S CHEATING ON HIS
WIFE.
WHAT I USED TO WORK AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT YOU DID THAT
YOU'RE OUT.
YOU KNOW WHY?
THEY DIDN'T WANT YOU TO BE BLACK
MAILED, OF ALL PEOPLE, THE
RUSSIANS.
NOW WE THERE'S MORE TEXTS THAT
SUGGEST HE'S BEEN LEAKING TO THE
MEDIA.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THIS
IS AS OF SIX MONTHS AGO,
FASHIONED 125 LEAKED STORIES,
ONE LEAK A DAY CONTAINING
LIKES WITH THE CAPACITY FOR
NATIONAL SECURITY SCORED ABOUT
TIMES AS FAST AS UNDER BUSH.
MALT JORT OF THE LIKES DURING
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, AGAIN,
THIS IS AS OF SIX MONTHS AGO, 78
CONCERN THE RUSSIAN PROBE.
NOW, TALKING ABOUT THE RUSSIA
PROBE WE HAVE A SPECIAL COUNSEL
DOES NOT EXIST TO INVESTIGATE
FINANCIAL CRIMES, WHETHER SOME
GUY REGISTERED AS FEDERAL AGENT
OR SO FORTH.
HE'S TO INVESTIGATE COLLUSION.
WHAT'S IT BEEN, SIX MONTHS,
EIGHT MONTHS?
THIS DOSSIER.
THIS ISN'T A DOSSIER.
THIS IS 35 PAGES OF CRAP THAT
WAS PUT TOGETHER BY THE FUSION
GPS.
THE HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND
THE DNC COLLABORATED, USED THEIR
MONEY TO USE A LAW FIRM TO HIRE
THIS GUY WHO THEN HIRE AS
BRITISH EX-SPY WHO THEN WORKS
WITH AMONG OTHERS THE KREMLIN.
THAT'S COLLUSION.
THEY PUT THIS THING TOGETHER AND
THEY WORK IT AND THEY GIVE IT TO
THE FBI.
THEIR PAYROLL.
WHAT DO THEY DO WITH IT?
I KNOW THEY USED IT.
>> Sean: I KNOW THEY DID, TOO.
>> TO GET A FISA WARRANT.
WHY WON'T THE FBI DIRECTOR OR
WHY WON'T ANYONE AT DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE WHEN THEY'RE ASKED
SAY NO IT WASN'T USED.
>> Sean: MARK, ROD ROSENSTEIN --
>> HOLD ON, NOW.
THAT DOES NOT REVEAL CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
JUST SAY NO WE DIDN'T USE IT.
BUT THEY WON'T SAY IT.
IT.
WE CONFIRMED LAST WEEK THEY USED
I HAD ONE REPORT THAT SAID IT
WAS PUSHED OVER THE TOP.
ROD ROSENSTEIN WENT INTO SPEAKER
RYAN'S OFFICE ACCORDING TO MY
STUFF.
HERE'S THE QUESTION, LAST
QUESTION, YOU HAVE A MINUTE TO
GO.
WE, THE MEDIA -- THIS IS WHY I
WANT YOU ON EVERY WEEK.
WE HAVE A MEDIA THAT, OH, THEY
PUT --
>> WE DON'T.
>> Sean: THEY PUT WOODWARD AND
BERNSTEIN ON A PEDESTAL.
MEDIA THAT NOW IS SO BIASED,
ABUSIVELY SO, COMPLICIT EVEN.
THEY TALK ABOUT WATERGATE.
MARK, THIS WAS ABOUT INFLUENCING
A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
USING FISA WARRANTS, RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA, HILLARY DNC BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR.
I THINK IT'S BIGGER ON A SCALE
THAT WE DON'T KNOW YET.
IT WILL BE BIGGER.
>> YOU KNOW TO GET A FISA
WARRANT YOU NEED TO HAVE
PROBABLE CAUSE THAT SOMEBODY IS
AN AGENT OR ACTING AS AN AGENT,
JUSTICE TELL US EXACTLY WHAT THE
RUSSIAN AGENT WAS ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN?
THERE WASN'T ANY RUSSIAN AGENT.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE HELL THE
FISA JUDGE IS BUT THEY SHOULD BE
FURIOUS AND DEMANDING ABSES TO.
THIS AS FOR THE MEDIA IN THIS
COUNTRY, WE HAVE FREE PRESS.
THAT'S FINE.
WE ALSO HAVE A STUPID PRESS.
WHEN I WATCH THIS GUY, BRIAN
SELTZER WHO I REALLY -- THIS DON
LEMMON OR OVER THERE, THE
PRESS?
I CALL IT A JOKE.